[Music]
Billy eilish and Jesse Rutherford call
it quits we're all just doing our thing
you know what I'm saying ET can confirm
the two split amicably and remain good
friends this is what I want Reps for the
artists tell ET both are currently
single while also shutting down any
rumors of cheating it's unclear when
exactly they decided to end the
relationship I mean I just think it's
like
if it's something you you feel just like
do
[Music]
and I don't know that sounds like super
basic but it literally is
Billy and Jesse Sparks dating rumors now
in October when they were spotted having
dinner at a Los Angeles restaurant dude
here's the thing bro multiple public
sightings later the pair confirmed their
relationship sharing this pic on
Instagram from Halloween of the duo
seemingly poking fun at their age Gap
the then 20 year old Billy dressed as a
baby while 31 year old Jesse sported an
old man costume
the couple then made their red carpet
debut at the LACMA art and film Gala
matching in Gucci and just a month after
going IG official Billy sat down with
Vanity Fair completely smitten over the
new romance can we just
Round of Applause for me
thank you
Jesse Rutherford everyone
hold his ass all me I did that
I locked that down I don't even know at
the time the singer also opened up about
her love languages which includes
freedom
you know I don't want to be controlled I
want to be trusted and I want to be able
to have space that's all I'd say to be
honest with you
foreign